[Music]
rihanna
is officially a billionaire
robin rihanna fenty was born on the
beautiful island of barbados in 1988.
she grew up in a small bungalow with her
two younger brothers and her parents
who had a rocky relationship rihanna
always loved music and grew up singing
along to reggae artists like bob marley
and boujou bantam as well as vocal
powerhouses like mariah carey
whitney houston celine dion and shania
twain
from a very young age she knew she
wanted to become a star
rihanna's big break came when she was in
high school one of her friends in school
introduced her to a vacationing music
producer right in a hotel
rihanna sang for him forever changing
the trajectory of her life
he flew her to the u.s where they worked
on a demo album
and went on to audition for none other
than jay-z
within 12 hours of that she was signed
to def jam
she released her debut album music of
the sun in 2005.
one year later she dropped her platinum
selling sophomore album
but her third album good girl gone bad
shot rihanna into major stardom
earning her her first grammy dad
i know i promise you i'm gonna give you
my first grammy
but we might have to fight for this one
from there she released hit after hit
[Music]
she was a global phenomenon touring all
over the world
her face was everywhere and she secured
several high-profile partnerships with
beauty and fashion brands
as well as successful perfume lines
but it wasn't until 2017 that she
launched the brand that would take her
to billionaire status
and would make her the first black woman
with creative control at a major fashion
house
her makeup line fenty beauty was one of
the industry's first inclusive lines
offering 40 different shades of
foundation
the brand co-owned with french luxury
goods giant lvmh
was an immediate hit in 2018
rihanna launched savage x-fenty and in
she launched fenty skin also with lvmh
this february her lingerie line savage
x-fenty
raised 115 million dollars in funding at
a one billion dollar valuation
today forbes estimates rihanna's net
worth at 1.7 billion dollars
and her clara lionel foundation which
raises money from fans and supporters
has made donations to coronavirus relief
efforts
to new york's needy to abuse victims in
los angeles
and more
[Music]
you